the main staging post for any action by
britain would most likely be from the
raf akatori air base in cyprus
now it's believed that raf tornado gr4
jets there would be ready to bomb is
targets as soon as the order is given
tornadoes have been conducted
surveillance missions over iraq since
they arrived in the area last month
the jets can be equipped with missiles
including the storm shadow that's a
long-range missile capable of traveling
150 miles at just below the speed of
sound this could be used to attack
targets inside syria but from iraqi
airspace
the paveway laser guided bomb is another
part of the arsenal which can be fitted
to the jets weighing between 500 and
1100 kilograms they've been used by the
raf in afghanistan
they use hydraulic wings and they can be
steered to target with the guidance of a
laser or using gps
armed drones could also join the
operations the raf has about 10 armed
reaper reconnaissance drones in
afghanistan these could be deployed in
iraq or jordan this would be the first
time that the uk has used armed drones
outside afghanistan